schönen guten abend willkommen zu zdf
heute live der krieg in der ukraine ist
schlimm und jetzt wächst auch wieder die
angst vor einer nuklearen katastrophe
denn am wochenende ist das
ukrainische atomkraftwerk zerbricht
erneut beschossen worden beide seiten
die ukraine und russland geben sich
gegenseitig die schuld daran was droht
bei solchen angriffen und wie groß ist
die gefahr einer nuklearen katastrophe
darüber wollen wir heute abend sprechen
mit sebastian stransky von der
gesellschaft für anlagen und
reaktorsicherheit und außerdem gibt uns
ex nato general egon ramms später noch
seine einschätzung zur aktuellen
militärischen lage sie und ihr könnt
eure fragen stellen oder meinungen
posten das geht am besten in den chats
oder eben auch per mail wir legen gleich
los vorher bringt uns lauter rosinus auf
den aktuellen stand
überreste von raketen auf dem gelände
des atomkraftwerks sapori cia gestern
veröffentlicht es ist das größte in ganz
europa mehrfach ist es in den
vergangenen tagen ziel von angriffen
geworden präsident sei lenski fordert
internationale
reaktionen
es gibt keine nation auf der welt die
sich sicher fühlen kann wenn ein
terroristischer staat ein atomkraftwerk
geschossen gott bewahre wenn etwas
irreparable es passiert wird niemand den
wind auffalten der die radioaktive
verseuchung verbreiten
russland weist jede schuld von sich
wirft der ukraine vor das atomkraftwerk
selbst beschossen zu haben dabei seien
stark stromleitungen beschädigt worden
teilte das russische
verteidigungsministerium mit die
produktion der anlage habe deshalb
gedrosselt werden müssen unabhängig
überprüfen lassen sich diese
informationen nicht
rauchschwaden über dem atomkraftwerk
seit freitag ist es mehrfach angegriffen
worden die messwerte vor ort geben
jedoch kein hinweis darauf dass
radioaktivität ausgetreten sein könnte
das teilte das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz mit schon einmal stand
die anlage unter beschuss rückblick märz
seither so sagt die ukraine haben sich
russische truppen auf dem gelände
verschanzt
die anlage in sapporo china ist veraltet
und wartungs bedürftig die
atomenergiebehörde spricht von einer
sehr realen gefahr einer nuklearen
katastrophe
auch un-generalsekretär guterres fordert
internationalen experten zugang zu dem
atomkraftwerk zu ermöglichen
jeder angriff auf ein atomkraftwerk ist
eine selbstmörderische sache und ich
hoffe dass diese angriffe aufhören
werden denn wie vielen angriffen das
atomkraftwerk in zukunft stand halten
kann ist unklar
sebastian stransky von der gesellschaft
für anlagen und reaktorsicherheit guten
abend guten und strand geht das ist ein
thema das vielen menschen angst macht
und wir wollen heute abend versuchen mit
sachlichen informationen zu einer
einschätzung zu kommen schon mal danke
dass sie uns dabei unterstützen also ein
atomkraftwerk in einem kriegsgebiet wird
angegriffen wie schätzen sie die gefahr
für einen nuklearen katastrophenfall ein
also ich würde als dass es vielleicht
sagen wollen dass das was da gerade
passiert aus meiner sicht etwas flapsig
zu sagen ein absolutes no go ist also
ein kernkraftwerk ist es
sicherheitstechnisch
zertifizierer angelegenheit und eine
sehr diffizile einrichtung und das ist
teil von kampfhandlungen wird oder ein
kampf handlungen direkt oder indirekt
eingebunden ist etwas was wir uns vor
einigen monaten noch nicht habe
vorstellen können und es ist eine
traurige realität und ich würde sagen es
sollte so schnell wie möglich beendet
werden und die truppen sollten so
schnell wie möglich abziehen um auf ihre
frage zu kommen das hängt davon ab wie
stark die anlage durch kampfhandlungen
beschädigt werden würde es ist so dass
wenn bestimmte anlagen teile von
geschossen oder raketen getroffen würden
würde es nicht automatisch zu schweren
schäden führen das würde auch nicht
automatisch zu einer
kernschmelze zu einem kern spaß unfall
mit einer freisetzung von einer großen
menge radioaktivität führen sondern das
hängt wirklich von dem ganz konkreten
handlungsablauf ab es gibt ein paar
neuralgische punkte in dem kernkraftwerk
auf jeden fall aber vom grundsatz her
sind diese reaktoren so wie sie auch im
support stehen durch ereignisse von
außen geschützt das heißt ein einfacher
beschuss oder ein einfacher treffer auf
das reaktorgebäude oder eines der
nebenanlagen gebäude würde nicht
automatisch zu einer nuklearen
katastrophe oder zu einem ich sag mal
nuklearen unfall führen ich finde den
begriff nukleare katastrophe ist ein
sehr sehr starker begriff und ich würde
dann doch eher den begriff nuklearer
unfall oder die kerntechnische unfall
wählen wollen gehen wir vielleicht
zunächst einmal in die details der
porsche ist ja das größte atomkraftwerk
in europa von welcher größenordnung
sprechen wir da wie müssen wir uns das
vorstellen und in welchem zustand
befindet sich dieses atomkraftwerk also
es ist insofern das größte kernkraftwerk
europa aber nur dann wenn man den
standort als ganzes betrachtet stehen
dort sechs einheiten sechs blöcke würden
wir sagen und jeder dieser blog hat eine
elektrische energie erzeugung oder eine
elektrische die möglichkeit elektrische
energie von 1.000 megawatt zu erzeugen
das ist weniger als zum beispiel die
derzeit noch laufenden deutschen
kernkraftwerke haben also sowohl das
kraftwerk isar 2 neckarwestheim 2 oder
auch im emsland haben ungefähr 1400
megawatt elektrische leistung die sie
erzeugen können es ist insofern
natürlich das größte europas war der
sechs blöcke stehen das heißt netto wäre
die leistung die dort erzeugt werden
könnte 6000 megawatt das ist schon eine
ganze menge allerdings muss man dazu
sagen dass diese sechs blöcke autonome
sind das heißt jeder block arbeitet für
sich und ist unabhängig von den anderen
fünf blöcken
gebaut wurden die blöcke in den 70er und
80er jahren die technologie kommt aus
den 70er jahren wir sagen das ist die
zweite generation von kernkraftwerken
zur energieerzeugung generation zwei
kraftwerke sie besitzen ein stahlbeton
containment das kann man auch sehen wenn
man auf google maps auf den standort
geht kann man sich die sachen von oben
durchaus angucken diese star bekommt
ebert hat zwei funktionen einmal soll
dass es die inneren
einrichtung des kraftwerkes den ersten
kreislauf den reaktor verein wirkung von
außen schützen zum beispiel auch vor
einem flugzeugabsturz und auf der
anderen seite soll das containment auch
die umwelt schützen sollte es im inneren
zu einem unfall kommen mit freisetzung
von radioaktiven stoffen so sollten
diese fr die aktiven stoffe im inneren
des containments zurückgehalten werden
und nicht in die umgebung zu gelangen
und die umgebung zu gefährden die
anlagen sind seit anfang der 18 jahren
betrieb sie sind hintereinander gebaut
worden verschiedene inbetriebnahmezeiten
bekommen auch im internet nachlesen ich
schätze so ein dass die anlagen durchaus
einen technischen stand haben wie wir
sie in westeuropäischen anlagen zb
nachbarländern von deutschland auch
finden die anlagen sind seit einigen
jahren unter nachrüstung die ukraine hat
freiwillig als nicht-eu-mitglied an dem
sogenannten europäischen stresstest
teilgenommen der für alle europäischen
kernkraftwerke oder für die
kernkraftwerke in der europäischen union
nach fukushima verbindlich
festgeschrieben war und der eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung dieser
kernkraftwerke gegen äußere einwirkungen
wie sie in fukushima passiert sind
beinhaltet hat die ukraine hat diesen
stresstest freiwillig gemacht für alle
ihre anlagen die in der ukraine stehen
und auf der basis der ergebnisse dieses
stresstests ist ein nachrüstprogramm
entwickelt worden dieses programm
befindet sich in der umsetzung bestimmte
sachen der nachrüstung sind
abgeschlossen bestimmte teile sind noch
nicht abgeschlossen so dass ich
einschätzen würde das die blöcke in
sapporo trotz ihres alters durchaus in
einem sicherheitstechnisch besseren
zustand sind als zu ihrer errichtung
ganz einfach weil man zusätzliche
sicherheitseinrichtungen mit denen man
bestimmte störfall szenarien beherrschen
kann nachgerüstet hat sie sind aus
meiner sicht von stand her durchaus
vergleichbar mit anlagen die in
westeuropäischen ländern stehen dazu
fragt skandal auf youtube um wieviel
spaltbares material und sprengkraft
reden wir wie sehr entspricht das den
sicherheitsstandards gegen terrorismus
im zuge von nine eleven wurden die
sicherheitsmassnahmen getroffen
also wie viel er ist genau drin tonnen
das kann ich nicht sagen da will ich
jetzt nicht spekulieren da müsste ich
selbst nachgucken das habe ich natürlich
jetzt nicht im kopf es ist spaltbares
material in form von uran die oxid in
tablettenform das ist kein material was
man als sprengstoff bezeichnen kann ein
atomkraftwerk ein kernkraftwerk ist
keine atombombe und ist überhaupt nicht
damit vergleichbar und zu solch einer
explosion wie zb bei einer bombe oder
bei der bomben hiroshima würde es sind
keine matura in einem kernkraftwerk der
welt kommen können das hängt einfach mit
der geometrie und auch mit der
anreicherung des urans zusammen
maßnahmen zur sicherheit gegen
terroristen haben alle kernkraftwerke
der welt ergriffen aber das sind
natürlich maßnahmen die nicht der
öffentlichkeit auf dem teller
präsentiert werden sondern das
entspricht den inneren
sicherheitskonzepten aber ich muss noch
einmal sagen es ist so dass sie nicht
mit dem beschuss einer artilleriegranate
oder auch mit einer panzerfaust ein
kernkraftwerk zu zerstören könnten oder
schädigen könnten dass es automatisch zu
einem unfall kommt jetzt ist es ja so
diese situation muss man sich erst mal
vorstellen da arbeitet weiter
ukrainisches personal während dieser
anlage seit dem ersten angriff im märz
von russischen militär kontrolliert wird
unter welchen umständen arbeiten die
menschen dort und was macht das was ist
das für ein sicherheitsrisiko
also unter welchen umständen leute
arbeiten kann man nur spekulieren weil
ich habe mit keinem den arbeiter
gesprochen auch wir haben natürlich zu
den kraftwerks leuten keinen direkten
kontakt wir haben kontakt regelmäßig zur
ukrainischen aufsichtsbehörde oder auch
zur ukrainischen partner organisation
meiner firma das ist die organisation
ssc cnrs quasi die techniker safety
organisation würden wir im englischen
sagen tsu
wir kriegen natürlich immer nur indirekt
nachrichten aus sapporo cher was wir uns
natürlich vorstellen können eines der
grundprinzipien des sicheren betriebes
eines kernkraftwerks ist natürlich neben
der technischen sicherheit der anlage
auch die organisatorische sicherheit und
das bedeutet dass das betriebspersonal
ungestört von äußeren einflüssen ohne
stress und ohne druck arbeiten sollen
selbstständig entscheidungen treffen
soll ich mir vorstelle dass das schicht
personal mittlerweile seit fast fünf
monaten ich glaube sogar mehr als fünf
monate unter der russischen besatzung
arbeitet ich weiß nicht wie dieses
besatzungsregime das ganz konkret
ausgestaltet dass aber ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass
der stresspegel unter den schicht leuten
durchaus ein sehr hoher ist das kann
natürlich auch zu menschlichen fehlern
führen das heißt dass der eine oder
andere vielleicht auch in einer handlung
falsch macht ein ventil fall schaltet
oder auch ein schalter fallstrick das
will ich nicht unterstellen aber
sicherlich ist es nicht auszuschließen
aber man muss dazu sagen dass
kernkraftwerke grundsätzlich gegen
solche sachen auch ausgelegt sind dh es
ist nicht möglich durch eine schallt
handlung den reaktor in eine solche
situation zu bringen dass es zu einem
kern schmerz unfall kommt sondern er
würde dann wenn eine schaltung schallt
handlung zur abweichung von betriebs
parametern kommt führt dann würde der
reaktor automatisch abgeschaltet werden
und in den sicheren zustand gehen es
gibt auch bei den kernkraftwerken der so
genannte konzept ist ihnen täters das
heißt man will auch verhindern dass
durch eine missbräuchliche handlung
reportage würde man das vielleicht
nennen eines personal weise eines
angehörigen des personals ist zu einer
gefährlichen situation kommen können uns
allen ist ja der unfall in fukushima in
erinnerung was würde passieren wenn es
ins labor ist ja auch zu einer
kernschmelze komme
das hängt davon ab in welchem zustand
die äußeren gebäude einheiten sind
normalerweise sind die anlagen so
ausgelegt dass wenn ist zu einer
kernschmelze käme was ich immer noch für
eine sehr hypothetischen fall halte weil
es gibt diverse
sicherheitseinrichtungen aktiver natur
und auch zusätzliche mobile
sicherheitseinrichtungen die
nachgerüstet und die genau das
verhindern sollen wenn es denn zu einer
kernschmelze käme und der
reaktordruckbehälter also das gefäß das
muss man sich vorstellen wie einen
dampfkessel wo der kern drin ist würde
kaputtgehen der kern wurde aus dem
reaktordruckbehälter raus fließen nach
unten in ihre akte grube dann würde er
sich erst einmal da unten in den
strukturen in den beton strukturen
verteilen dann würde es zu einem
druckaufbau und kommt dem kontinent
kommen und dann hängt es von
verschiedenen faktoren ab ob der druck
im containment so hoch ist dass das
containment versagt oder ob das konnten
mit diesem druck standhalten kann
wenn das konnten mit dem druck standhält
passiert gar nichts dann bleiben die
radioaktiven stoffe im inneren des
containments eingeschlossen und es gibt
keine große freisetzung sollte das konto
versagen dann kann es durchaus sein aber
das ist ein hypothetischer fall dass
radioaktive stoffe freigesetzt werden
aber genau für einen solchen fall sind
diese anlagen nachgerüstet worden das
heißt man hat das container den
stahlbeton behälter mit ventilen
ausgestattet die im fall der fälle den
druck aus dem kontinent entlasten können
so dass das containment nicht
kaputtgehen würde bei einem überdruck
aber wie gesagt das hängt wirklich ganz
von dem konkreten szenario ab und das
kann man nicht prognostizieren man kann
so etwas rechnen wir wollen bei uns in
der firma das auch etwas genauer uns
angucken haben eine arbeitsgruppe
gebildet mit der wir uns gerade auch
einem beispiel frischer uns das angucken
wollen gerade weil wir diesen reaktortyp
dieses kraftwerk sehr gut kennen nicht
nur von technologischen aufbau her meine
mitarbeiter sind also mehrfach schon am
standort gewesen und auch in anderen
kernkraftwerken mit den ukrainischen
kollegen oder ich will schon fast sagen
partnern sehr eng zusammenarbeiten und
wir wollen uns das mal angucken was
wirklich an realismus realistisches
szenario sein könnte
wir bekommen natürlich eher relativ
viele fragen rein was das in deutschland
bedeuten würde gerade vortex schreibt
zum beispiel auf youtube wie gehen wir
damit um in deutschland falls es zu
einem nuklearen gau kommt was könnte man
tun oder errol aufschreibt was sollten
sollten wir in deutschland tun im falle
eines nuklearen unfalls dass sie
natürlich fragen die die menschen hier
umtreiben ja das kann ich sehr gut
verstehen dass die menschen das umtreibt
das treibt mich auch um das ist ja klar
als ich angefangen habe reaktortechnik
so studie 1986 war ja nur gerade fünf
monate her dass wir auch mit ein grund
warum ich mir warum ich das studiert
habe weil ich verstehen wollte was da
passiert ist was ist für auswirkungen in
deutschland hätte das hängt auch
wiederum von vielen faktoren ab das
erste der erste faktor wäre natürlich
oder der erste punkte zu beachten wäre
wie viel kommt dann wirklich raus aus
dem reaktor wenn er denn kaputt ging und
das containment kaputt geht das kann man
zwar theoretisch prognostizieren wie
fields aber in wirklichkeit ist hängt
mir gesagt von dingen ab die wir auch so
nicht prognostizieren können der zweite
punkt ist welche witterungssituation
haben wir das heißt von wo aus weht der
wind wenn der wind so weht wie ja
meistens wird nämlich aus westen wie wir
es bei uns ja haben die westwetterlage
in den meisten fällen dann würden wir
davon überhaupt nicht betroffen würden
dann würde das unheimlich gut vielleicht
darf ich da ganz kurz einen haken denn
expertinnen vom karlsruher institut für
technologie haben ja genau diese modelle
nach denen eine wolke in dieser
jahreszeit eigentlich hauptsächlich
richtung osten gehen würde heute wäre es
kein guter tag gewesen heute hätte der
wind radioaktivität er in eine andere
richtung getrieben nämlich richtung
westen in dieser simulation für das zdf
sieht man bei einem schweren störfall im
atomkraftwerk buschehr heute mittag
hätte sich die radioaktivität man muss
betonen hätte innerhalb der ersten 36
stunden in richtung südwesten
ausgebreitet über odessa nach rumänien
bulgarien bis in den norden der türkei
also besonders dort wo die karte orange
eingefärbt ist man sieht es wäre die
millisievert belastung dann so hoch dass
menschen in diesem szenario evakuiert
werden müssten was sagen ihnen solche
modelle was halten sie davon
solche modelle sind sehr wichtig und
solche modelle haben wir natürlich auch
in deutschland und auch die zuständigen
behörden dass das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz hat solche modelle und
solche ausbreitungsrechnungen können
auch gemacht werden
ich habe da jetzt so die farben gesehen
also ich kenne weder den quell term
denen das paket für als als grundlage
für die berechnung genommen hat was
natürlich wirklich zu sehen ist und das
ist einleuchtend die verschiedenen
farben deuten auf die verschiedenen
kontamination geben oder die konnten
verschiedene kontamination level hin
konsument aktions niveaus und daraus
resultierend natürlich die
strahlenbelastung wenn man sich denn in
diesen bereichen aufhält
das wäre natürlich schon so in den
ersten 36 stunden würde ist dann zu
einer solchen kombination kommen können
wenn es eine
großflächige oder eine eine große menge
radioaktiven wenn eine große menge
radioaktiver nuklide freigesetzt werden
würde und das könnte auch zu solchen
dingen führen wobei ich natürlich jetzt
nicht absehen kann das habe ich aus der
der farbigen grafik nicht ersehen können
wie hoch wäre dann zb die die mögliche
strahlenbelastung beim aufenthalt in
moldova in rumänien oder bulgarien aber
vom grundsatz her ist das natürlich sehr
sehr realistisch auf jeden fall das
wären hat noch eine frage auf youtube er
hat eben gefragt nachdem radius der
nuklearen verseuchung das haben wir
jetzt eben gesehen aber er schreibt auch
könnte dass russland selbst treffen das
zeigen die modelle ja auch und wie weit
ist publisher von moskau entfernt das
könnte russland treffen oder ich denke
immer zuerst würde es den den
angrenzenden teil von russland treffen
also das was sie da sehen kann man sich
ja einfach mal andersherum sehen also
ich weiß nicht von von satoris bis
bulgarien sind sich vielleicht 1000
kilometer luftlinie
und wenn man einfach mal sagt der wind
weht könne aus der anderen richtung das
1000 kilometer in richtung osten sonst
natürlich tief in russland oder 1000
kilometer in richtung norden sind
weißrussland oder auch in russland
russland wäre bei einem kerntechnischen
unfall im labor ist weiß gott nicht
davor gefeit eventuell auch in eine
radioaktive wolke und damit in eine
kontamination zu kommen und so fahren
umso unverständlicher warum diese kämpfe
dort geführt werden noch eine frage auf
youtube was wäre wenn das kraftwerk
abgeschaltet werden muss hätte das eine
auswirkungen auf den europäischen
strommarkt nein nein die ukraine ist
zwar seit märz mit dem europäischen netz
synchronisiert das heißt ursprünglich
war die ukraine weißrussland und
russland als ehemaligen staaten der
sowjetunion verbunden dass das elektro
energienetz aber die ukraine hat
justament an dem tag und das war
eigentlich eine koinzidenz ein zufall an
dem tag als der krieg begann am 24
februar sich vom weißrussischen und
russischen netz getrennt um einige
wochen später sich mit dem europäischen
netz also mit unserem energienetz zu
synchronisieren nennt man dass das heißt
zu verbinden gleiche frequenz das ist
immer der der punktgleiche phasen und
die ukraine könnte jetzt ins europäische
netz einspeisen das will sie auch wie
viel strom verkaufen natürlich will
damit auch das europäische netz
stabilisieren allerdings ist es so dass
die leistung die zurzeit eingespeist
werden kann in das netz nicht so groß
ist dass es zu einem signifikanten
einfluss auf das europäische netz käme
wenn in der ukraine keinen strom mehr
produziert wird schauen wir vielleicht
noch mal auf die anderen atomkraftwerke
in der ukraine wie sicher sind die
ja wie sicher sind die das ist immer
eine sehr allgemeine frage sie
entsprechen dem aktuellen
sicherheitsstand den der in der ukraine
national gefördert gefordert wird und
der auch dem sicherheitsstand entspricht
den die internationale
atomenergiebehörde empfiehlt oder ich
will nicht sagen vorschreibt weil das
ist freiwillig aber
der erwartet wird von kernkraftwerken
dieses alters und dieser generation und
auch diese kernkraftwerke sind
nachgerüstet worden sowohl das kraftwerk
in rock oder in riga im nordwesten der
ukraine als auch das kernkraftwerk in
chemnitz die in der zentral ukraine oder
das kernkraftwerk süd ukraine im süden
der ukraine
jetzt will die internationale
atomenergie-behörde
beobachter nach afrika schicken für wie
realistisch halten sie das dass das
klappt und was würde das bringen ich
denke es hängt nur von der entscheidung
der russischen militärführung ab wenn
die russische militärführung sie ist
damit einverstanden und ich glaube dass
auch die entscheidung letzten endes in
moskau getroffen werden muss dann werden
sicherlich die
experten der internationalen
atomenergieorganisation da hinfahren
können ich halte das persönlich auch für
wichtig einfach um auch ein zeichen zu
setzen und sich vor ort das wirklich
anzugucken die frage ist natürlich ob
das militär wirklich den experten
gestattet alles das zu sehen was sie
sehen wollen denn wir dürfen uns nicht
vergessen wir haben einen zustand den
sich von uns einig so niemand hat
vorstellen können also die meisten
menschen bei uns in europa haben krieg
nicht erlebt einschließlich auf meiner
person wir sind viel zu jung um uns das
vorstellen wie das ist wenn jemand unter
kriegsrecht lebt und soldaten quasi das
sagen haben oder auch generäle das sagen
haben und jammert die situation dass
über das kraftwerk de facto dass die
armee die russische armee das sagen hat
und sie bestimmt ob die leute dahin
fahren können oder nicht ich persönlich
halte es durchaus für wichtig dass die
experten der iaeo dahin fahren
allerdings sollte das auch dann
natürlich in absprache mit den ukrainern
geschehen denn eins dürfen wir nicht
vergessen das ist nach wie vor ein
ukrainisches kraftwerk es wird von
ukrainischen experten betrieben und ist
sollte eigentlich auch wenn es auch
derzeit nicht möglich ist unter der
aufsicht der ukrainischen atom
aufsichtsbehörde stellen für stransky an
dieser stelle ganz herzlichen dank für
ihre informationen und ihre einschätzung
ich danke ihnen sehr gerne
ja und wir haben ja eingangs gesagt wir
wollen uns die situation auch noch mal
militärisch einschätzen lassen und dazu
begrüße ich jetzt ex nato general egon
ramms guten abend herr
gans die ukraine und russland
beschuldigen sich gegenseitig dieses
kraftwerk wieder angegriffen zu haben
was würde ein beschuss welcher seite
bringen wie ist ihre einschätzung
dass ein größerer nuklear unfall
passieren könnte das ist erst mal eine
erfreuliche feststellung ob sie in jeder
form so gilt ist eine frage die ich als
nicht nuklear fachmann in dieser form
nicht beantworten kann
ich habe kein verständnis dafür dass um
dieses kraftwerk bereits im märz 22 märz
gekämpft worden ist und ich habe auch
kein verständnis dafür dass ich jetzt
russische truppen offensichtlich auf
diesem kraftwerk verschanzt haben ich
gehe aufgrund der militärischen
situation und der interessenlage von
ukrainischer seite her davon aus dass
die ukrainische seite weder ein
interesse daran hat dieses kraftwerk zu
beschießen noch dieses kraftwerk in
kampfhandlungen einzubeziehen man muss
da auch vielleicht ein bisschen
reingucken in das erste zusatzprotokoll
zur genfer konvention ist in den
artikeln 50 bis 56
oft merken schon eine besondere position
gibt und dann schützen würdig bezeichnet
von daher sollte man da sehr vorsichtig
mit sein also kampfhandlungen um dieses
kraftwerk herum machen keinen sinn das
einzige was ich als erklärung im
augenblick bieten kann ist
offensichtlich die tatsache dass die
russen in der nähe des kraftwerkes
unterlamm auch auf die einheiten
stationiert haben und damit hoffen dass
die japanischen streitkräfte diese rust
statt l'oreal hat und der nähe des
kraftwerks nicht bekämpfen und damit
sich im prinzip noch eigene schutzzone
geschaffen haben zu ihrem eigenen
vorteil
was ja auch nach kriegsrecht verboten
ist oder
ich wiederhole was ich gerade gesagt
habe es geht um das erste
zusatzprotokoll zur genfer konvention
die artikel 50 bis 56 dort wird
atomkraftwerken schutz entsprechend
eingeräumt von daher sollte man in einem
großen kreis um ein atomkraftwerk rom
keine kampfhandlungen durchführen aber
wir haben miterlebt im märz dass die
russen jahr an diesem kraftwerk
entsprechende vorstöße gemacht haben und
das kraftwerk auch militärisch in ihren
besitz gebracht haben was ich nicht für
eine gute maßnahme damals gehalten habe
und welches durch die entwicklung heute
nochmal bestärkt wird dass das der
falsche weg gewesen ist dazu schreibt
marx vom orc hoffentlich offensichtlich
wird vor nichts mehr zurück geschreckt
mester second schreibt kaum zu glauben
dass er so ein spiel gespielt wird das
ist doch nicht zu fassen bei einem gau
gibt es keine gewinner was soll das
also da gibt es eine von meiner seite
her ganz einfache antwort darauf die
lautet mit der aggression gegen die
ukraine am 24 februar mit der
entwicklung der kampfhandlungen vom 24
februar bis heute hat die russische
seite nachdrücklich unter beweis
gestellt dass sie weder auf völkerrecht
noch kriegsvölkerrecht noch konventionen
oder sonstige dinge beachtet das ist im
prinzip alles an verträgen in diesem
bereich gebrochen wurden und die
russische seite scheint das nicht zu
interessieren und da kommen
möglicherweise auch noch erschwerend
dazu dass der militärische befehlshaber
general wesley brasilien in diesem
kraftwerk das kommando führt hoffen sich
der aalener von denen ist der ich sage
mal gewalt und auch dinge die nicht
zugelassen sind offensichtlich ganz
gerne einsetzt heute abend kommen
nachrichten über twitter von
ukrainischer behördenseite das russische
soldaten das gelände vermint haben
sollen das können wir jetzt natürlich
nicht verifizieren aber könnte ein
solches vorgehen eben zur russischen
strategie zur vorgehensweise in diesem
krieg passen
es passt in das große bild rein nun dass
die russische seite ich sag mal
sicherung solche dinge die eigentlich
durch gesetze durch verträge oder
konventionen eingeschränkt sind
offensichtlich nicht hält in dieses bild
passt dass und das ist auch eine
tatsache die wir auf unserer seite mal
in aller deutlichkeit zur kenntnis
nehmen müssen einfach aus dem grunde zur
kenntnis nehmen müssen um diese
situation in der ukraine und das
verhalten der russischen soldaten und
damit auch der russischen regierung
entsprechend realistisch einzuschätzen
denner und hier gab es auch die frage es
gibt gerüchte dass die russen das
atomkraftwerk vermint haben was ist da
dran die haben wir damit schon mal
beantwortet andere frage von wolfgang
auf youtube kann die nato oder ähnlich
deine angriffszone um die lkws errichten
mit luftverteidigung
nein das kann die nato nicht weil sie
damit auf ukrainischem boden müsste und
wir wollen nach wie vor die nato aus
gefechtshandlungen in der ukraine
heraushalten weil wir einen
unmittelbaren konflikt zwischen russland
und der nato oder allen nato staaten wo
wir ja auch zu gehören in jedem falle
vermeiden wollen diese linie hat die
nato seit dem 24 februar sehr konsequent
sehr gut um sehr zuverlässig eingehalten
jetzt sagt man sind an der richtung sagt
das mal ganz kurz noch mal die vereinten
nationen sind in der richtung ich sage
das jetzt leider werde ich den vereinten
nationen gerne eine andere rolle
zuordnen würde ein zahnloser tiger die
die ukraine hat darf die die usa dafür
keine militärischen mittel wirklich ist
ja auch nicht in der lage druck
auszuüben oder das was in den in der
un-charta oder in entsprechenden
internationalen verträgen steht mit
militärischer gewalt durchzusetzen dass
sie kann es nicht um sie wird auch im
sicherheitsrat der eine solche
entscheidung treffen müsste die mehrheit
dafür nicht kriegen ich gehe davon aus
dass die dass die russen dieses mit
einem veto blockieren würden und die
chinesen möglicherweise einem solchen un
einsatz zum schutz von atomkraftwerken
auch nicht zustimmen würde und dann gibt
es noch mal eine frage von uwe jacobs
auf youtube wer hätte denn ein vorteil
wenn es hoch geht wir haben ja eben
gesehen eine radioaktive wolke würde
auch möglicherweise richtung russland
ziehen wo wäre der vorteil
ich darf diese frage vielleicht war von
einer anderen seite anfassen trotz der
aussagen die
experte zu dem thema sicherheit der
atomkraftwerke oder der ältesten
reaktoren gemacht hat ich fast dass von
der anderen seite an und sage das sage
dass die ukraine in meinen augen
überhaupt kein interesse daran haben
kann dass irgend eines ihrer
atomkraftwerke auf ukrainischem boden
einen sogenannten gau also den größten
anzunehmenden unfall erleidet weil die
ukraine hat ja selber erlebt zwar noch
zu sowjetzeiten 1986 tschernobyl was das
bedeutet hat und wir sehen heute noch
den sarkophag für das kraftwerk in
tschernobyl und wir haben eine
evakuierungszone tschernobyl rum in die
nach wie vor noch kein menschen nein
darf und die nach wie vor nachhaltig
verseucht sind das heißt wenn die
ukraine dieses auf ihrem eigenen boden
provozieren würde dann wäre das etwas
was ich harakiri nennen würde und ich
kann das an vernunft denkende mensch und
die ukraine hat in den letzten woche
vernünftig gehandelt kann ich das
einfach nicht zuordnen hier müsste jetzt
eingreifen möglicherweise wladimir putin
silber zumindest aber der
verteidigungsminister der russlands um
diesen generalmajor der möglicherweise
ich kann das weder bestätigen noch
dementieren minen auf dem gelände des
kraftwerks gelegt hat zu mäßigen und
möglicherweise auch mit seinen truppen
teilen von diesem kraftwerk abzuziehen
um dann wieder den prozess einleiten zu
können dass die internationale energie
atomenergiebehörde oder organisation
dieses kraftwerk entsprechend
kontrollieren überprüfen kann aber das
hängt wie bei vielen anderen situationen
in diesen angriffskrieg russlands gegen
die ukraine von den entsprechenden
entscheidungen der russischen regierung
ab sie haben die karten in der hand und
sie müssen sie spielen oder so wie
bisher dann lassen sie es und dann
finden wir möglicherweise und auch in
andere schwierige situationen an
motor schreibt dazu auf youtube fakt ist
dass man auf telegramm sieht wie sich
die russen brüsten dass sie schon
sprengsätze
angebracht haben vielleicht schauen wir
noch mal auf diese internationale ebene
hallo welt fragt würde bei einem gau
einen ator antwort folgen
nein wie damals in tschernobyl 86 auch
wenn ein größter anzunehmender unfall
dort passieren würde an nukleare unfall
passieren würde wäre das keine sache in
die die nato als sicherheitsbündnis des
westens sich einmischen könnte wenn die
nato handeln wollte was sie nicht will
das betone ich noch mal in aller
deutlichkeit dann hätte das präventiv
oder vorher spätestens jetzt erfolgen
müssen aber das ist nicht die absicht
der nato sich aufgrund dieser
krisensituation die bedeutung der
ukraine haben in die kampfhandlungen
zwischen der ukraine und russland
einzumischen vielleicht versucht nochmal
die gesamte situation im süden der
ukraine zu betrachten so fischer liegt
ja im süden der britische geheimdienst
sagt dort sammeln sich die russischen
truppen im moment was sagt das aus
also die ukraine verkündet ja schon seit
einigen wochen etwa vier wochen dass sie
die absicht hat richtung saison
anzugreifen und die ukraine hat
vermutlich in diese richtung ein ich
sage mal zumindest operatives interesse
die das rechten flussufer des 10er pro
wieder in eigene hände zu bekommen und
auf diese art und weise zwischen den
teilen die russland gesetzt hat und dem
was dann wieder in den händen der
ukraine wäre ja eine natürliche barriere
nämlich diesen großen fluss zu legen
es ist schwierig im augenblick zu
ermessen festzustellen zu belegen wie
die kampfhandlungen tatsächlich
verlaufen und durch erfolge die ukraine
haben aber sie haben offensichtlich
erfolge denn die kräfte die zurzeit
offensichtlich auch nach der aus nach
den auskünften des britischen
geheimdienst dorthin verlegt werden
kommen erkennbar aus dem don das und
dann donners wissen wir auch sind die
kampfhandlungen auch im augenblick ich
sag das mal vorsichtig bis auf geringe
geländegewinne der russen in der region
denn jetzt mehr oder weniger eingefroren
das heißt die russen brauchen
zusätzliche kräfte um offensichtlich um
den rapper zu halten und auf diese art
und weise auch das westufer inszenierte
in eigenen händen zu behalten um die
ukraine hat ein großes interesse daran
ihnen dieses weg zu nehmen weil sie
damit einen natürlichen schutz hat der
sich vor weiteren angriffen aus dem
süden beziehungsweise aus dem südosten
schützt heute abend gab es jetzt noch
die eilmeldung dass russland die us
inspektionen im rahmen des new start
abkommens vorerst stoppte was ist das
für ein abkommen und was bedeutet dieser
schritt
ist ein juhu start abkommen ist ein
abkommen gewesen welches ende der 80er
jahre geschlossen worden ist und welches
letztendlich die sagt das mal atomare
rüstung auf dem strategischen sektor
also strategischen raketen begrenzt und
in teilen sogar reduziert hat das ist
ein trick haben sowie dax war das
auslösende moment dafür und das ist der
dazugehörige vertrag zu diesem vertrag
gehört auch dass beide parteien also die
russen in amerika und die amerikaner in
russland die nuklearen abschluss
stellungen vergleichbare dinge
entsprechend überwachen kontrollieren
können
um zu belegen dass man sich an dieses
abkommen hielt diese inspektion finden
mehr oder weniger regelmäßig statt und
wenn russland diese inspektionen jetzt
für sich
inspektionen auf russischem boden
aussetzen will dann ist das erst mal
kein gutes signal aber das gefährdet den
vertrag nicht wobei ich mir da eine
anmerkung erlaubt sei es ist eigentlich
der letzte noch funktionierende
rüstungskontroll vertrag den wir dort
haben und es wäre auch gut wenn er
weiter funktionieren und arbeiten würde
einfach um zu vermeiden dass auf der
strategischen ebene ein neuer
rüstungswettlauf beginnt ich danke ihnen
sehr für ihre informationen und ihrer
einschätzung und wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend
herzlichen dank
ja und auch ihnen und euch vielen dank
für die vielen wichtigen fragen und
meinungen ich wünsche noch einen schönen
abend bis bald